[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
aujourd'hui nous recevons jean
christophe picard bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes président depuis 2000 15 d'anticor
association qui lutte contre la
corruption et prône l'éthique en
politique vous êtes l'auteur de ce
nouveau livre la colère et le courage
plaidoyer contre la corruption pour une
république est éthique c'est aux
éditions armand colin
le débat ensemble éternelle c'est le
sens de la préface que signer l'ancien
procureur de la république eric de
montgolfier c'est quoi pour vous fils
république éthique
écoutez c'est une république qui se
préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable pour dire pour rétablir la
confiance entre élus et électeurs
confiance indispensable en démocratie et
puis pour des raisons ne serait-ce qu
économique le coût de la corruption et
est évalué à pour la france chaque année
à 120 milliards le coût de la fraude
fiscale entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque
année donc c'est s'aider des sommes
colossales que chacun d'entre nous doit
supporter évidemment cet argent pourrait
être beaucoup mieux employés et on en
est loin aujourd'hui en france de cette
conception vous défendez quelles sont
les grandes failles dans notre pays il y
en a beaucoup
il y en a beaucoup je crois que d'une
part on est un peu dans le déni ou
encore une fois des ya pas de chiffres
officiels du coût de la corruption
contrairement à certains pays
contrairement par exemple à l'europe n'y
a pas non plus en termes de moyens les
moyens adéquat pour en termes
d'enquêteurs en termes de juges en
termes de procureur nous avons les
procureurs les plus occupées de tous les
pays du conseil de l'europe les plus
débordés et il n'y a pas non plus
l'indépendance nécessaire des procureurs
pour justement on va dire couper tout
lien entre le ministre qui est souvent
perçu était politique et les procureurs
qui ont la monopole du déclenchement des
poursuites en france donc on a
énormément de problèmes de failles et
puis il ya l'éternel problème du cumul
des mandats dans le temps et dans
l'espace qui renforce on va dire les
l'opacité qui sclérosent beaucoup la vie
politique en france
mais alors majoritairement en france a
abouti à quel type d'affaires c'est de
la corruption à proprement parler
du conflit d'intérêts qu'est ce qui
revient le plus souvent dans l'hexagone
alors c'est la corruption sens large ça
recoupe pas seulement la corruption ça
recoupe aussi évidemment évidemment les
prise illégale d'intérêt le lobbysme
parfois le le favoritisme concussion
enfin il ya une ribambelle derrière le
mot le mot générique de corruption il ya
une ribambelle de deux délits derrière
ça qui d'ailleurs changé c'est un peu
comme le dopage qui évoluent les
techniques évoluent en fonction du
progrès de la lutte antidopage en france
à la corruption c'est pareil c'est une
multitude de délits qui change de forme
qui changent de nature qui s'adapte
lorsque les lois petit à petit et c'est
de réguler par exemple à un moment donné
on a régulé le financement de la vie
politique bien sûr s'adapter on a vu que
ça se déportait sur d'autres d'autres
domaines donc on est on est toujours on
va dire chaque chaque année on nous
avons nous découvrons des pratiques des
combines et ccc sans fin c'est un peu
comme sisyphe qui doit sans fin lutter
contre les nouvelles pratiques de
corruption et une absence de réelle
volonté politique politique finalement à
chaque affaire les responsables
politiques tentent d'un d'éteindre
l'incendié en cours en répondant avec
des propositions immédiates sur le coup
mais il n'y a pas une réelle envie de
faire changer les mentalités sur le long
terme
non j'ai pas le sentiment effectivement
qu'une réelle volonté en fait
effectivement quand un scandale fait du
bruit on se sent obligé de réagir et de
prendre quelques mesures on l'a vu à
kalsaka été capé remis la création la
haute autorité pour la transparence dans
la vie publique la création du parc
national financiers ça a été un énorme
progrès on l'a vu avec la sphère fillon
où on a un petit peu encadré le
recrutement familiale au parlement donc
on voit bien qu'on attend on attend les
scandales et on va réagir sur le
scandale mes parents pour prendre
l'exemple de 2,2 du recrutement
familiale c'était c'est bien
d'effectivement d'interdire le
recrutement famille assez mais c'est pas
non plus la mesure phare à prendre
aujourd'hui pour moraliser les pratiques
donc on voit bien qu'on en attend
pour réagir mais ya pas une vision
d'ensemble n'ya pas une volonté vraiment
de de lutte et de prendre à bras le
corps ces problèmes
peut-être qu'il ya encore une fois un
manque de lucidité d'une certaine classe
politique
et pourtant ce thème de la moralisation
politique n'est pas nouveau on se
souvient de nicolas sarkozy qui avait
défendu une démocratie irréprochable lui
qui est aujourd'hui empêtré dans
plusieurs dossiers judiciaires avant lui
après lui françois hollande a effet de
la république exemplaire
le programme de sa campagne de 2012 et
vous l'avez rappelé on se souvient de la
sphère cahuzac
et puis emmanuel macron lui aussi lors
de sa campagne électorale il avait
prévenu que le principal danger pour la
démocratie était la persistance de
manquement à la probité pas remis à des
responsables politiques ce sont ses
termes
symboliquement les deux premières lois
qui vont été adoptée sous son
quinquennat furent dites de moralisation
de la vie politique comment est ce que
vous expliquez que ça ne fonctionne pas
à cette moralisation de la vie politique
mais que les candidats à la
présidentielle elle continue de la
prôner à quoi est-ce qu'ils sont
confrontés
une fois qu'ils arrivent au pouvoir sans
doute un manque de sincérité quand on
effectivement proclame une république
irréprochable exemplaire avec eux on
n'essaye pas de la construire parce
qu'évidemment elle sera pas créé de main
mais on peut vraiment on peut améliorer
on voit ce qui se passe en scandinavie
donc ce qu'on propose que anticorps
propose et ce qui se passe en ce qu en
mairie c'est pas de la science fiction
ça existe dans certains pays
dans les pays où il ya une grande
transparence yen faible corruption et
comme par hasard ce sont les pays où les
gens se sentent le plus heureux
puisqu'il ya une sorte d' indices chaque
année qui s'appelle indice de bonheur
sont les pays scandinaves où les gens se
sentent plus heureux ce qui est logique
parce que l'argent est bien utilisé bien
en distribuer donc il y a il ya une
vraie différence entre les discours et
les acteurs pourquoi en france parce que
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation
rappelez-vous philippe seguin qui avait
théorisé la fameuse prime à la casserole
qui constatait que tous les élus un peu
véreux était réélu cette prime à la
casserole est toujours là regardez
patrick balkany il ya 44 % des habitants
de levallois qui disent on veut re voter
pour lui alors qu'il est en prison enfin
donc c'est complètement dingue
donc à partir du moment où la population
les citoyens ne réclame pas cette
moralisation effectivement les élus ne
sont pas pressés puisque puisqu'ils sont
ils dépendent des voix et ont ils vont
être bien que ce n'est pas un ressort
dans les urnes au moment de voter il ya
une responsabilité collective voire
citoyenne c'est ce que vous y c'est
exactement ce que je dis dans mon livre
il faut arrêter de pointer du doigt les
élus les élus en démocratie ce sont nous
qui votons pour eux il ya une
responsabilité collective à tous les
niveaux
c'est un peu d'ailleurs la kz2 mon livre
on sa part du président en allant
jusqu'aux citoyens en passant par les
élus locaux les candidats aux élections
les militants dans les partis politiques
etc
on a tous une responsabilité évidemment
on peut tous agir à notre niveau
évidemment que le président république a
plus de pouvoir qu'un simple citoyen
c'est une évidence mais à notre niveau
on peut agir il ya des votants en
participant aux décisions et des
procédures en france de démocratie
participative qui existent qui sont
d'ailleurs peu utilisé ce qui est quand
même un paradoxe puisque on réclame
d'aider d'autres procédures alors que
celles qui existent sont peu utilisées
on voit bien donc 7,7 ce paradoxe qui
est le citoyen à une doit reprendre sa
place et doit sanctionner les élus
indélicats et doit promouvoir au
contraire ceux qui proposent des mesures
visant à éviter les abus
parce que finalement quel est le risque
avec cette impression d'impunité de la
part de certains responsables politiques
c'est que le lien s'abîme entre
électeurs et élus et ça aboutit
finalement à des crises comme celle des
jets les jeunes un lien défiance
qu'est-ce que ça c'est mélanger les
jaunes c'est rien par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé dans certains pays il ya des
pays où mais les hommes politiques dans
des poubelles
donc s'il faut éviter ça nous nous
sommes en tout cas on n'est pas contre
les élus on est pour défendre les élus
on est pour réhabiliter la démocratie
représentative et on dit si on n'entend
pas l'exaspération d'une partie de la
population on va arriver effectivement
des crises il ya énormément de
mouvements sociaux qui ont abouti de par
le mandat des révolutions
en partie à cause de la corruption ces
pays-là qui dans d'autres pays est
beaucoup moins supporter qu en france et
donc il faut retrouver cette confiance
pour éviter ce qu'on a connu en 2010 est
c'est à dire le dégagisme on a dégagé
tous les partis de gouvernement on a mis
un nouveau parti et qui lui-même risque
s'il ne prend pas la mesure de ses
responsabilités d'être dégagée aux
prochaines élections donc pour éviter on
va dire c'est mon mouvement brutal qui
peuvent aboutir
peut-être des choses plus graves il faut
prendre en compte c'est il faut lutter
contre les abus pour effectivement que
le lien norman normale est indispensable
de confiance entre élus et électeurs
soit recrée alors vous évoquez la sphère
cahuzac du nom de l'ex ministre du
budget sous françois hollande qui avait
on le rappelle dissimulé au fisc de
l'argent à l'étranger
cette affaire a abouti à la création de
la haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique c'est bien le
résultat d'une certaine prise de
conscience mais manifestement ça n'est
pas suffisant aujourd'hui il faut se
rappeler le lendemain d'affaires cusack
la classe politique pensé qu'elle allait
devoir fuir à l'étranger enfin je veux
dire c'était la panique complète et ils
ont lâché des choses extrêmement
importantes effectivement la création de
la haute autorité qui est qui fonctionne
très bien le parquet national financier
qui est très utile même s'il y a que 18
magistrats
c'est quand même le super parquet de
france et qu'il n'y a que 18 magistrats
on a aussi permis la l'agrément des
associations comme anti corses qui nous
permet nous de nous constituer partie
civile et d'éviter parfois que certains
dossiers politiques soient soient
enterrés donc ça a été très utile donc
mais là la classe politique l'a fait on
va dire parce qu'il y avait une panique
en ce qu'il faut
remémorez l'état d'esprit à l'époque je
veux dire un pivot eva joly qui disait
on est au bord de la deûle implosion et
c'est donc quand c'était il y avait
cette panique et on pense qu'il n'est
pas nécessaire d'attendre
des scandales de cette ampleur pour
améliorer faire progresser les pratiques
et qu'on peut pourrait le faire de
manière sereine et sans attendre les
scandales pour le faire dans votre livre
personne n'était pas renié députés
français députés européens élus locaux
ministre finalement tous pourris c'est
le sombre tableau que vous peignez alors
surtout pas au contraire non non c'est
une non at il de faire prendre
conscience que les choses peuvent
évoluer alors anticor a été créée par
des élus on n'est pas du tout entier lui
ou tous pourris au contraire moi je dis
que c'est pas le cas il ya effectivement
des élus qu'on laisse en liberté qui qui
est la soeur dont la réputation est
rejet sur les autres gars des balkany on
l'a laissé sévir 30 ans alors qu'on
avait en 1988 les premiers articles du
canard enchaîné daté de 1988
il ya eu plusieurs rapports de la cour
des comptes qu'il ya eu des enquêtes si
on aurait pu d'ailleurs je les écris au
présent appuyé j'ai demandé sa
révocation n'aurait pu leur évoqué
plusieurs fois les habitants auraient pu
ne pas le réélire donc pendant trente
ans on l'a laissé sévir c'est à dire
toute la population enfin tous les
citoyens à tous les niveaux l'ont laissé
sévir
mais comment est-ce que vous l'expliquer
justement est une forme de banalisation
de certaines pratiques lorsqu'on et
politiques qui sont admises par certains
électeurs
je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre de
courage par d'amples présidents vont
j'ai écrit à hollande il ya macron pour
qu'ils leur évoque ce nombre ne l'ont
pas fait c'est un manque de courage ils
avaient ce pouvoir là de révoquer les
citoyens ont été achetés il faut le dire
ils sont transformés non pas en
électeurs mais en clients certains ont
reçu des cadeaux ils sont fait acheter
donc c'est une responsabilité collective
c'est ce qu'ont dit nos anticorps il
faut pas se contenter ce serait un peu
facile de pointer du doigt les élus il
faut démocratie faut regarder les
responsabilités à tous les niveaux et
chacun dans chaque acteur de la vie
politique a un rôle à jouer
merci jean christophe picard vous restez
avec nous c'est la fin de cette première
partie de la grande interview on fait
une pause et on se retrouve après
[Musique]
et vous êtes avec nous pour la seconde
partie de la grande interview nous
sommes avec jean christophe picard
président depuis 2000 15 d'anticor
association qui lutte contre la
corruption et prône l'éthique en
politique
auteur de ce nouveau livre la colère et
le courage plaidoyer contre la
corruption pour une république éthique
c'est aux éditions armand colin à la
liste est longue des affaires qui ont
éclaboussé le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron depuis qu'il est arrivé au
pouvoir en 2017 il n'a pas été plus
épargné que ses prédécesseurs à l'elysée
dernière affaire en date jean paul
delevoye l'ancien monsieur retraites du
gouvernement qui est entré au
gouvernement en septembre 2019 qui a
doublement enfreint on le rappelle les
règles prévenant les conflits d'intérêts
en continuant d'être rémunéré pendant
trois mois par un think tank en omettant
de signaler à la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique
plusieurs mandats qu'il a occupé au
cours des dernières années il a
sous-estimé aussi certaines de ces
rémunérations alors on va peut-être pas
tous les citer mais on peut aussi parler
assez rapidement de françois bayrou
sylvie goulard marielle sarnez les trois
piliers du modem du modem qu'un ministre
dans le premier gouvernement d'edouard
philippe contraintes démissionné au bout
d'un mois car soupçonné d'avoir organisé
ou bénéficier d'un système d'emplois
fictifs d'assistants parlementaires au
parlement européen il est aussi françois
de rugy l'ancien ministre de l'écologie
qui lorsqu'il était président de
l'assemblée nationale organiser des
dîners à l'hôtel de lassay avec son
épouse des dîners personnel aux frais de
la princesse françoise nyssen l'ancien
ministre de la culture soupçonnée
d'irrégularités lors de travaux sur les
locaux par les parisiens et arlésiens de
son ancienne maison d'édition actes sud
richard ferrand actuel président
d'assemblée nationale mise en examen
pour prise illégale d'intérêts dans la
sphère des mutuelles de bretonne dans
laquelle il est accusé d'avoir favorisé
sa campagne sa compagne lors d'une
transaction immobilière
il y en a encore d'autres ça vous
inspire quoi c'est à faire aujourd'hui
bah écoutez ça commençait déjà pendant
la campagne
rappelez vous la faire
sion cas complètement parasiter cette
élection et peut-être même fausser le
résultat là aujourd'hui les affaires
aussi pèse sur la vie politique sur
l'efficacité finalement du gouvernement
donc on voit bien l'intérêt de prévenir
et de lutter contre la corruption pour
éviter effectivement qu'on est toutes
ces démissions qui affaiblissent qui
perturbe un gouvernement et donc on perd
du temps de l'énergie et puis après il
ya évidemment le volet pénal sur la
responsabilité individuelle des uns des
autres mais ça ça porte atteinte à dire
l'efficacité finalement de du pro de la
politique du président ont voulu par le
président mais aujourd'hui la
moralisation de la vie politique est
quelque chose c'est une notion qu'on a
tous en tête les électeurs sont très
sensibles à certains à certains faits
comment est ce qu'on explique malgré
tout ces responsables politiques ce
ministre ne soit pas plus sensibilisés
mais continuent à enfreindre les règles
ben écoute et on l'a vu avec la campagne
présidentielle quand il yal'affaire pin
up fillon la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème parce qu'il
faisait tout ça depuis des années la
sphère des assistants parlementaires
européens ils sont sidérés parce que
tout le monde fait ça il n'ya pas
d'ailleurs qu'un seul parti qui
épinglait n'y a pas que le modem il ya
aussi le front national il ya aussi la
france a soumises qui sont un peu dans
le collimateur donc on voit bien que ces
pratiques étaient répandues et qui a été
fait depuis si longtemps qu'ils sont
très étonnées finalement qu'à un moment
donné on dise on arrête donc il ya un
moment de sidération
avec cette classe politique est là
depuis longtemps peut-être qu'avec la
nouvelle génération on peut espérer que
les nouvelles pratiques plus saines se
met en place rapidement mais je crois
très clairement qu'ils ne comprennent
pas où est le problème
mais ce que les choses ont malgré tout
évolué dans le bon sens ces dernières
décennies
ce que vous avez le sentiment que
il ya des choses qu'on s'autorise mois
quand on est au pouvoir oui bien sûr
encore une fois chaque scandale a permis
de progresser et je crois qu'on a une
chance en france et là d'avoir une
presse déjà presse pluraliste et
beaucoup de journaux d'investigation
beaucoup de journalistes d'investigation
d'ailleurs anticorps on récompense
régulièrement remet des prix chaque
année on récompense régulièrement des
gens des investigations qui permet de
sortir des affaires et des affaires
parfois très importantes et donc ça ça
permet justement de mettre une pression
alors on a des associations agrées comme
anticorps qui met aussi un peu la
pression
on a eu des journaux on a parfois les
citoyens qui peuvent effectivement un
moment donné dire maintenant là on
cautionne plus enfin même si ce n'est
pas encore complètement flagrant hélas
mais voilà et ça c'est très sain d'avoir
on va dire cette pression sur sur la
classe politique
alors on ne peut pas évoquer les
affaires sans parler de celle qui fait
la une de l'actualité ces derniers jours
carlos ghosn la sphère carlos ghosn
kalanga reste que vous portez dessus
coup d'essai un petit peu désolant de
constater que parce qu'on a de l'argent
peut choisir en quel pays on va être
jugés
choisir on peut décréter que voilà on
n'est pas jugée
avec justice qu'on a voilà donc ça ça
montre bien aussi qu'ils nous ne sommes
pas tous des justiciables sur le même
niveau que certains peuvent s'autoriser
et parce qu'ils ont de l'argent a
justement fuir leurs responsabilités
donc c'est c'est extrêmement choquant et
j'espère qu'on à l'avenir mettre en
place des mécanismes pour empêcher ce
type de de tourisme judiciaire puisque à
priori monsieur legault ne saute ça va
choisir là où il va du j'ai donc c'est
assez désolant évidemment d'avoir ce
type de pratiques comment est-ce que
vous travaillez chez anti corse est une
association elle a été créée en 2003
vous en est le président depuis 2015
avec quels fonds est ce que vous pouvez
vous pouvez mener à terme vos missions
alors pour garantir notre indépendance
nous refusons toute subvention
donc nous font ces simples sont les
cotisations on a presque 4000 adhérents
et les dons des dons privés donc qui
nous permettent d'avoir un petit peu de
moyens peu un finalement mais un petit
peu on a deux permanents un petit local
et la majorité de notre argent est
utilisé pour payer les frais d'avocat
puisqu'on nous sommes engagés dans une
centaine d'affaires aujourd'hui quelles
sont les affaires les grandes affaires
du moment chez anticorps affaires alstom
la sphère kohler la sphère ferrand la
sphère des sondages de l'elysée qui
remonte déjà à quelques années mais
c'est très très lent puisqu'on a déposé
plainte en 2010 et nous sommes en 2019
donc on annonce un renvoi en
correctionnelle loyer neuf ans sans même
avoir de jugement et aussi ce problème
là delà de la durée des procès des
procédures qui font que voilà
heureusement qu'on est cons et là depuis
longtemps et qu'on a un peu d'argent
pour pour rester encore très longtemps
en fonction
vous vous sentez un peu celle au sein
d'anticorps est ce que vous êtes soutenu
comment est ce que vous vous ressentez
les choses vous qui qui est une sorte de
garde-fou pour tenter de moraliser la
vie politique on se sent pas si seul que
ça d'ailleurs chaque année on remet des
prix tic justement pour montrer qu'il ya
des bons comportements il ya des gens
courageux il ya des journalistes il ya
des élus la leur la cérémonie aura lieu
demain et on va récompenser un député
qui est très courageux dans ce qu'il
fait on a en récompense des chercheurs
on récompense des des lanceurs dallaire
donc heureusement on n'est pas seuls
sinon ce serait très difficile
et d'ailleurs on a aussi le nombre
d'adhérents qui croît chaque année nous
encouragent
ce serait difficile parce que
effectivement la pression est terrible
la pression les menaces les plaintes en
diffamation dénonciation calomnieuse
évidemment nous sommes nous subissons
tous à ce qu'on appelle les procédures
bâillon les déclarations dures d'impôt
tic à notre égard ce que contrairement à
ce qu'on peut penser on n'est pas très
populaire dans la classe politique même
s'il en est ce que vous avez des menaces
ou est ce que vous vous êtes sentir un
peu bousculé dans vos approches des
menaces non on a beaucoup de courriers
d'avocat qui nous met en garde
bon ça nous impressionne pas beaucoup
mais oui on a beaucoup de cette pression
là on a des plaintes contre nous en
dénonciation calomnieuse et diffamation
mais moi ce qui me
m'étonne beaucoup c'est que des députés
donc déjà en charge est quand même de
représenter la nation et de défendre
l'intérêt général en fait mettre en
cause régulièrement anticorps parce qu'à
un moment donné on va attaquer quelqu'un
de leur camp et or ces démarches et vous
avez le sentiment de danger mais s'ils
voulaient nous notre idée c'était de ré
est de réhabiliter la démocratie
représentative et lorsqu'on voit des
députés qui défendent leurs petits
copains qui utilisent leurs mandats
député pour défendre leurs petits
copains et à attaquer des associations
de lutte contre la corruption
composée de bénévoles est déçu et qui
vident de leurs propres dont je pense
que ça abîme encore le lien que nous on
souhaiterait réhabiliter donc sonné un
petit peu triste de voir ça et à chaque
fois c'est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est une certaine génération de
députés est ce qu'on peut avoir l'espoir
que les plus jeunes se tiennent encore
éloigné de ses pratiques il ya quand
même des jeunes députés qui ont vite
pris le pli ya quand même on regrette
beaucoup d'ailleurs on avait plus
d'espoir avec cette nouvelle génération
députés on pensait que ça allait
peut-être aller un peu plus vite mais on
remarque que certains ont pris quand
même très très vite de mauvaises
habitudes et on voit bien pendant le le
vote de la loi sur la confiance dans les
politiques on voit bien que les nouveaux
elle nouvelle génération n'a pas été à
la hauteur de nos attentes et que
beaucoup de mesures importantes comme
par exemple le casier vierge pour être
candidats sont passés à la trappe
elle vous évoquez le rôle des lanceurs d
alerte aujourd'hui
on en parle depuis pas si longtemps que
ça finalement leur rôle est considérable
début octobre une directive européenne a
été adoptée afin de mieux protéger ses
lanceurs d alerte
ces nouvelles règles doivent être
transportés transposée par les états
membres d'ici à deux ans où est-ce qu'on
en ait en france est ce que vous êtes
invités à participer justement
l'élaboration de ce statut d'élève des
lanceurs d alerte en france alors oui en
tout cas on est régulièrement invitée au
sénat où l'assemblée nationale pour pour
les textes qui rentre dans notre objet
donc on nous avons dans parme dans la
loi sapin 2 nous avons pu défendre une
définition plus large du lanceur d
alerte que celle qui était prévue
initialement le lanceur d alerte c'était
uniquement celui qui dénonçait des faits
de corruption alors que dans la pratique
ce sont beaucoup de plutôt de faits de
fraude fiscale qui sont énoncées donc on
a réussi des associations pas que
anticorps mais toutes les associations
ont réussi à faire pression pour
justement que cette définition soit plus
large est aujourd'hui un lanceur d
alerte c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui va
dénoncer un délit ou un crime ou tout
préjudice grave à intérêt général donc
on voit bien que la définition est très
intéressante maintenant donc nous sommes
invités nous arrivons à évoquer nos
arguments on n'est pas souvent entendu
hélas mais au moins on est écouté
oui effectivement elle est très
important ces directives elle va faire
progresser les choses puisque
aujourd'hui en france il ya le système
du palier c'est à dire qu'un lanceur d'
alerte à l'obligation de saisir son
supérieur hiérarchique ou son employeur
ce qui est évidemment très dangereux
dans certains cas
puis ça permet si l'employeur et on va
dire dans le coup ça permet de faire
disparaître les preuves donc c'est
vraiment un dispositif un peu un presque
stupide puisque jean cyr d'alert par
définition il vaut mieux pas qu'ils
préviennent la personne qui va dénoncer
à l'avance donc l'europe fait sauter
cette système de palier on pourra
directement saisir l'autorité compétente
et l'europe permet d'élargir la la
protection des lanceurs d'alerté aux
proches par exemple ce qu'on appelle les
facilitateurs les collègues ou les
proches qui vont et des lanceurs d'alert
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas protégés par
contre le grand problème c'est toujours
le même le lanceur d alerte n'est pas
aidée financièrement ni en france ni
avec le futur dispositif puisque en fait
il n'y a pas d'obligation pour les états
de soutenir financièrement en allant sur
d'alert alors
frais d'avocat sont considérables
antoine deltour a dépensé 80 mille euros
dans la sphère luksic en frais d'avocats
donc c'est considérable il faut pouvoir
aider financièrement lanceur d alerte
comment est ce que en quelques mots la
france se positionne par rapport à ses
voisins européens et au reste du monde
dans cette éthique en politique est ce
qu'on est
on éloigne est très éloigné de ce qui
serait de d'excellentes pratiques en
politique
alors est-ce qu'on se positionne on à
peu près au milieu du tableau on est on
dit pas les mauvais élèves n'est pas les
meilleurs
alors c'est dommage parce qu'on est
quand même puis des droits de l'homme on
est un pays qui a beaucoup d'ambition et
voilà ce qui se passe en scandinavie
devrait pouvoir se passer en france
beaucoup plus de transparence beaucoup
plus de respect d'argent public
voilà donc c'est pas c'est pas
désespérer mais peut très largement
mieux faire au regard de deux notes
riche riche histoire et de nos moyens
financiers car vos solutions pour mettre
fin à ces abus c'est avant tout la
colère et du courage c'est le titre de
votre livre
ça commence par là oui alors la colère
je crois que beaucoup là et maintenant
c'est du courage et colère face aux abus
et le courage qui est je crois
incontournable au regard de des abus et
au fait que c'est notre avenir et
l'avenir de nos enfants qui est en jeu
donc c'est ce courage il est
indispensable pour pour préserver la
république et l'avenir de tous merci
beaucoup jean christophe picard nous
avons rendu visite sur rt france je
rappelle le titre de votre livre la
colère et le courage plaidoyer contre la
corruption pour une république éthique
c'est aux éditions armand colin
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis vous
père trouver l'intégralité de cette
grande interview sur notre site
rt france point tv à plus tard
[Musique]